un conseil pour les retardataires qui
comme moi n'ont pas acheté leurs cadeau
de Noël vous pouvez passer commande sur
internet histoire d'éviter la cohue des
grands magasins et ses interminables
files d'attente seul réserve toutefois
et bien de sérieux risques de fraude lié
au mode de paiement Dominique Vadel
Robin
toboule ça c'est le lieu conventionnel
des achats de Noël depuis des
générations où on a ses habitudes et
voici la version 98 de l'achat de Noël
branché la commande via Internet auprès
d'un magasin virtuel et tout absolument
tout s'achète sur internet en somme
comme dans un magasin classique mais
cependant les prévisions d'achat pour
Noël y reste encore modeste on s'attend
à 200000 acheteurs ce qui va représenter
avec une moyenne de 8 achats par
acheteur à peu près 200 millions de
chiffres d'affaires pour Noël donc en
fait 200 millions de chiffres d'affaires
sur le commerce électronique ça
représentera 1 % des achats de Noël nous
sommes au cœur d'une des cellules de
traackurs de fraude sur Internet leur
travail c'est de sécuriser les les
paiements et faire que numéro de carte
bancaire ou autorisation ne se promène
pas à Touvent sinon le commerce
électronique ne décollera pas vraiment
l'idéal disent les spécialistes ce
serait ça un boîtier personnel de
paiement relié à chaque ordinateur en
attendant ici on préconise le recours
classique et systématique à la banque
pour le paiement c'est inviolable et on
on fait d'abord confiance à la banque le
numéro de la carte ne circule plus c'est
meilleure sécurité qui puisse exister et
ensuite la la banque est responsable des
transactions et c'est elle qui se
chargera de débiter le client et de
régler le marchand chez Conforama comme
sur 750 sites on joue depuis cette année
la carte d'Internet mais c'est d'abord
pour voir en sachant que les habitudes
d'achat sont difficiles à modifier dans
la plupart du cas il regarde sur
internet catalogue il choisit les
produits fait son marché en quelque
sorte et après il peut aller en magasin
pour voir le produit et à partir de là
il décide d'acheter bref commerce
électronique ou pas il veut toucher
avant passer sa commande et les caisses
traditionnelles ont encore de beaux
jours à vivre même si on fait remarquer
qu'aux États-Unis cette année 7 millions
d'internautes vont acheter à Noël via
internet c'est deux fois plus que l'an
dernier